no one was better at kind of slipping a
slider by an unsuspecting lay audience
than Stephen because he was so
charismatic he was so brilliant and he
was so accomplished and such a brilliant
writer I started reading A Brief History
of Time in 1988 when I was a teenager
you know and and I stopped reading it in
1988 and then I picked it up again in
2020 and uh and and I started reading
and I finished it and found it you know
oh these objections are trivial so I was
like congratulating my you know all it
took is becoming you know a full
professor of physics stud uh but he's
actually a wonderful writer and uh but
the sophistication needed to understand
uh it's far beyond the fact that he
would say things that uh such as any
equation in your book cuts the
readership by half but any mention of
God doubles the amount of readers for
the book uh and of course I I only later
came to the conclusion of what he was
doing uh was really a sleight of hand
and it was um I believe somewhat dis
dishonest perhaps intellectually to do
what he did and I can say this because
uh I wouldn't I wouldn't expect that you
would say it although you hint strongly
at it but you're too much of a gentleman
to mention it and speak ill of the Dead
I love Stephen the problem I have with
him is that he would use in A Brief
History of Time this Hawking heartle
cosmology as a way to obviate the need
for a Creator as he said if God has two
roles according to Stephen Hawking who
was not a great Theologian although I'd
point out that he thought so much about
God that he actually was in Israelite
because the word Israel in Hebrew means
wrestles or struggles with God and
nobody struggled morally God than
Stephen Hawking and in fact the last
word words of his book that famous book
probably one of the most popular science
books in history sold three times more
copies as you point out than Richard
Dawkins blind watchmaker or The God
Delusion sold over 10 maybe 12 million
copies to date now uh the lobster best
sellers yeah yeah it was and it made a
whole publishing company and a whole
industry of popular science writing
which I benefit to this day so at the
risk of you know uh of killing the uh
the Golden Goose I would say you know he
in that book the final three words are
mind of God in other words if this is
proven to be true uh that uh in back in
1988 he believed that the Hawking heart
of cosmology would obviate the need for
God because God had two purposes one was
to instantiate the universe and the
other was to instantiate the laws of
physics the latter he disposed of
according to him in The Grand Design
another book with very strong theistic
overtones and atheistic overtones but
speaking of of A Brief History of Time
in that book he goes through what I only
later really recognizes you know after
going through graduate school basically
as he was doing this mathematical trick
of transforming time in a calculational
sense from proper time from physical
time which we enjoy and right now and we
can do experiments on and we can observe
things like time dilation and other
relativistic effects and he converted it
to this imaginary space which is purely
used for mathematical purposes to solve
equations which otherwise cannot be
solved without these techniques known
officially as Wick rotations to The
Experts playing at home and then he said
well it's just a mathematical trick and
then literally Stephen a page later it's
and now we see that there's no boundary
to time and therefore there is no need
for a Creator
um speaking harshly and as I assume you
know we'll find out when I read the rest
of Hawking Hocking which talks about him
as a commercial entity uh and uh but he
was not immune to using God as leverage
to influ to increase the influence of
his books and his thoughts in that book
that that that argument is really
falling deaf ears and worse than that
Steven maybe you would comment on this
is that in the revised updated Edition
in 2016 he not only says that uh the
more you know there's more evidence than
ever for the No No boundary theorem uh
but there's also evidence more evidence
for M Theory and inflation and I point
out this is two years after the bicep 2
Affair that I play a big role in so you
do indeed yeah what about what about
this need to to have Vindication to have
proof Etc why do why do you know sort of
these uh the headlines you know appear
on page one God is dead there's no God
Hawking says and then the response to
the community falls on deaf ears if at
all on page B17 of the of the Saturday
edition
well that was one of the things that I
mean you mentioned Lawrence uh class a
minute ago and I'm indebted to him for
uh getting me into this uh whole subject
of quantum cosmology I've been I've been
studying it a bit but in prepping for a
debate I read his popular book and then
that took me to the Lincoln and then
that got me not only I I was fortunate
enough to attend the lecture series that
Hawking did in preparation of the
release of A Brief History of Time When
I was a grad Student in Cambridge so
I've been aware of this for years but
um uh the in prepping for a debate with
Krauss I ended up getting into the
technical papers on Quantum cosmology
and that's reflected in in the last
three chapters of this book and one of
the things that I was shocked to find
was that this idea of the idea that the
wick rotation that eliminates in a in an
intermediate step in a longer
calculation the implication of uh a
singularity but only in the domain of
imaginary time or in the complex domain
of imaginary numbers
um that that
implication that he drew from that in
the Brief History of Time played
absolutely no role in his technical work
with hartle and that was something that
was purely offered for public
consumption and yet he as he pointed out
in the book itself uh the the idea of
imaginary time and the the uh the
depiction of the space-time geometry
that is possible during that
intermediate step in the complex domain
has no physical meaning and yet from
that Hawking drew a metaphysical
implication namely that there was not a
beginning to the universe and therefore
there was no Creator uh but then he
acknowledges that when you complete the
mathematical manipulation when things
are converted back into the real time in
which we live The Singularity reemerges
and this is one of the things that was
actually also very interesting is that
the singularity is presupposed in all of
the quantum cosmological modeling they
don't eliminate it it's only in this
popular popular work and if if I could
just cycle Circle back to the your
previous very astute question about well
you know there's always a new Cosmo
cosmology how can you draw any
significant conclusion from the whole
you know body of work in cosmology when
things are constantly changing one of
the things that's that's not changing
it's a constant is the need to account
for the specificity of our universe as
we find it and specificity in
mathematical terms is in a sense um
it it's a rarity of condition among a
vast Ensemble of possibilities and no
matter which cosmology is invoked there
is a need to there's a what's called The
Cosmic winnowing problem how do you
window among all those possible
ensembles of conditions and and and
possible states of Affairs how do you
account for our universe emerging out of
all this mathematical possibilities and
that problem is is ubiquitous it cuts
across the grain of different
cosmological models you find it in
Multiverse cosmologies where the
Multiverse is is
invoked whether it's based on
inflationary cosmology or string theory
or the combination of the two so you CR
you construct a Multiverse uh uh
cosmology to explain the fine-tuning but
then it turns out that you need a
universe generating mechanism to
generate the new universes in the
Multiverse and those generating
mechanisms themselves require prior
fine-tuning so you have the the need for
specificity the in addition and it's
left unexplained and the same thing
occurred and this is what fascinated me
in the in the cosmological case you can
you can circumvent the beginning problem
but only in the case of a deeper
information problem you have to you have
to account for the origin of the
specificity that is included in in the
case of quantum cosmological models the
universal wave function so
um so some of these problems that are
necessary to account for the origin of
the universe at all why we have
something rather than nothing and why we
have a specified something rather than
all the other things that could be are
not eliminated by any cosmological
Theory and in and instead continue to
beg the same types of questions
questions about the origin of
specificity of information where in our
experience we know of only one cause for
the origin of information for the origin
of specificity in that sense for the
origin of fine-tuning and that that that
causes a mind so there's a kind of
incorrigibility of the same type of
problems in all the cosmological models
and that's that's that's what I meant
earlier when I was referring to a kind
of the what I done in the book was
construct a robust argument one that was
not dependent on one model versus
another but rather upon the need to
solve certain basic classes of problems
that are only solved in our experience
by the by the postulation of of mind or
intelligence